[MUSIC PLAYING]
HANSON: American
citizens are threatened
by the loss of
their middle class,
by the loss of their
sovereign borders,
and especially from elites
of an administrative state
and globalism that
would surrender
our sovereignty to an
unknown body of world experts
or technocrats.
There are two million
people scheduled
to cross the borders
of the United States
between Mexico and America.
None of them are going
to enter legally,
no vaccinations
for COVID; there's
going to be no test
for COVID, solely
for the purpose of enhancing
the Progressive agenda
and the Democratic Party.
We have no border, and
there is no immigration law.
If we look, more importantly,
at the middle class,
we are emerging from a
pandemic, a population
emerging from quarantine, an
already inflationary cycle,
where we were not producing
goods and services because
of the quarantine,
or the population
was not growing in a
vast rate that would
justify printing more money.
And yet that's what we're doing.
And the result of it is, for
the first time in 30 years,
we have an annual inflation
rate of somewhere between 4.5%
to 7%.
Once interest
rates go up, people
will not be able to pay for
these inflationary prices
for cars, or major
appliances, or homes.
They'll stop buying, and
then we'll have a recession.
We're also in the
middle of something
I don't think any American
has ever seen before,
and that is a new woke movement.
What wokeness says
is, according to one
of its architects,
Professor Kendi,
and to the creators of the
Black Lives Matter movement,
is simply this-- because
of discrimination
in the history of
the United States,
it really can't be saved.
As Professor Kendi said,
to stop discrimination,
you've got to discriminate.
We now have to discriminate
by promoting people
on the color of their
skin in proportions
that are larger than their
percentages of the population.
As I speak, we have
people in confinement
who are apparently
charged with organizing
a riot or an armed insurrection.
The media told us that.
The investigatory
bodies told us that.
The Biden administration
told us that.
But here's the problem--
no one has been charged
with conspiracy.
No one has been charged
with racketeering.
No one has been charged with
organizing an insurrection,
because it was not
an insurrection,
as the FBI has recently found.
So what am I getting at?
I'm getting at the equal
applicability of the law
and the administrative
state's execution of the law.
We had a 120-day riot
that had just finished,
and that was the summer of 2020.
In 120 days of rioting, a
federal courthouse was torched,
a police precinct was torched
with policemen inside it,
a historic St. John's
Episcopal Church
right across from the
White House was torched.
If anything, it was called
a legitimate protest
against the Trump
administration.
It was much differently
portrayed in the press
and by the administrative state.
We've got to remember
that there is an agenda--
an international
cosmopolitan agenda--
by very wealthy people,
very sophisticated people,
very educated people.
And that's something
called the Great Reset.
Klaus Schwab, the architect of
the Davos group who discovered,
created, inaugurated
the idea that all
of the world's luminaries--
the best captains of industry,
the best Silicon Valley
architects of the
internet, social media,
the most impressive
military leaders,
politicians--
they could all assemble
at Davos, Switzerland,
among friends, even though they
were of different countries.
They all were so
enlightened that they
could agree that the
world was getting too hot
and there had to be an
international body that
overrode legislatures, or
dictators, or theocrats,
or democracies, or republics.
This group, now,
is very earnestly
trying to fan out through
their respective countries
to harmonize all of the
nations of the world
to turn over their sovereignty
to this select group.
In terms of globalization,
the COVID-19 pandemic
has been an opportunity
for globalists
to suggest that we
need more centralized
international and global power.
We have a lot of
politicians who feel that
under the cloak of fear
and national quarantines
and lockdowns that they
can change the system,
and therefore Governor
Newsom in California
said that perhaps during
the COVID pandemic,
we can have a more
Progressive form of capitalism
in the manner that
Klaus Schwab said.
Hillary Clinton said, perhaps
during the COVID lockdown,
it's an opportunity
to get a single health
care or more ambitious
government health care plan.
I think it was Jane Fonda, the
actress and occasional Davos
attendee, who said,
thank God for the virus
because it was a mechanism
to get rid of Donald Trump.
We've outlined all
of the challenges
to traditional citizenship,
but one thing is pretty clear--
that a majority of
Americans respect and
want to keep the
Constitution as it is,
and they feel that they're
the luckiest people
in the world because
they're American citizens.
As long as we remain the
majority of Americans
and remain vigilant, the
power under our system
is in our hands.